papa il le détestera d'office il est
plus intelligent que lui et ivoire c'est
avec cet homme que je veux passer le
reste de ma vieux lion britannique et
elle est fille de commerçants
c'était mon grand père à roi et moi je
suis sans héritier gilles icher aux
nombreuses responsabilités qui
l'attendent
mais je sais très bien que je ne pourrai
jamais réaliser quoi que ce soit si je
laisse mon coeur ici si vous décidez
d'épouser le dirigeant d'une nation
africaine
vous aurez responsable de la chute de
l'empiré britannique en afrique
vous devriez avoir honte tu peux me dire
à quel petit jeu tu t'amuses ça fait
plus de vingt ans quand tu prépares pour
que tu deviennes bras et que nous nous
revenir comme ça une femme blanche à
t'écouter
[Musique]
il semblerait que vous ne souhaitiez
plus que je m'acquitte de mon devoir de
vous servir comme moi parce que vous
n'aimez pas la couleur de peau de la
femme que j'ai choisi vous appartenez ou
plus en est ici et je suis prêt à vous
servir parce que j'aime mon peuple
sem c'était mais j'aime aussi ma femme
maintenant vous allez voir comment un
empire se défend monsieur camara nous
avons décidé qu'il serait souhaitable
que vous soyez exilés du veut être prête
noms
monsieur le ministre le monde entier car
les plus fortes que ce que nous pensions
il est temps pour nous de créer une
nouvelle nation
il est temps que nous devenions les
maîtres de notre destin et les temps